and what's stopping you from just
looking towards the ancient churches
what's stopping me is my conscience so
um I I've read through and I've I've
read through some of the early church
fathers how they believe baptism was uh
through
regeneration difference the um some of
the developments with the Mary because I
know how the Eastern Orthodox speaks
about it because I've been doing a deep
research in Eastern Orthodox they don't
believe they don't have the augustinian
view of original sin which is original
guilt so you're born corrupted and
tainted right uh the Orthodox Church
their view would be more Akin and the
Orthodox are here they can better
represent their position that we receive
a sinful bent but we are not sinful and
we're not born guilty and
condemned but later on as we mature and
attain cognition we're aware of our
existence and aware of choices that's
when we are held responsible that's when
that sinful bent arises to move us to
sin but if you ask the Catholics do they
believe if you ask the Catholics do you
believe that Mary was kept pure from
actual sin yes if you ask them you say
Catholics do you believe Mary
sinned in her life no did the Lord work
in in such a way by the grace procured
by her son that she never sin yes here
the Orthodox are here ask so I don't
want to speak for them they can speak
for themselves better than I can if you
ask the Orthodox did Mary ever commit
personal sin ever that absolutely not
that's why she's called panagia All
Holy by The Graces of her son so though
Catholics and Orthodox May disagree on
the nature of original sin and what that
entails and whether Mary had to be kept
pure from
conception they both agree she was kept
from any personal sin she never
committed any
sin where did they get this from because
if you go back in the early church
you'll see that she was believed to be
the new Eve and she undid the sin Eve
and she was the ark that gave to Christ
the fullness of his human nature for
example if I were to ask you if you
believe the Earthly
Tabernacle is a shadow of the Heavenly
one which it is if you go to Hebrews 8
and read Verses 4 to 5 the Earthly
Tabernacle is a shadow of the true
Tabernacle not made by human hands and
if you go to Hebrews 9 and if you read
23-28 it says Christ entered the true
Tabernacle not made by human hands so
the Earthly one is a shadow of the
Heavenly one so just like on Earth so it
is in heaven as it is in heaven may be
on earth so you have the heavenly
Tabernacle you have the Holy Place The
Altar and you have the most holy place
which is the mercy seat with the Throne
of God so on Earth you have the
Tabernacle you have the Holy place you
have the veil you have the most holy
holy of holies and Behind the Veil The
Mercy Seat the Ark of the Covenant which
represents God's throne and behind the
veil you have the tablets of stone where
God wrote the laws for Moses with his
finger the golden jar of mana and
Aaron's rod that but it now if you read
Leviticus 16 so I'm going to ask you a
question first it was the tabernacle
then the
temple because first day had a
tabernacle movable portable Tabernacle
then the temple in
Jerusalem the high priest could only
enter the most holy Place once a year
and he had to do so at his own Peril and
risk but first he had to make sacrifice
sacrifice aable for him and his family
if it was accepted then he'd have to go
back and bring in the blood of the goat
that was slaughtered into the most holy
place and if God accepted it he'd come
out of life but he couldn't remain there
and he'd have to enter after strict
purification washing changing his
clothes etc etc and that's just the
Earthly Tabernacle which is a shadow of
the Heavenly one in heaven you have the
Ark of the Covenant the mercy seed you
have the throne God the Father appearing
visibly visibly on a throne Christ in
his glorified physical body of Flesh
right there in the habitants of Heaven
seeing God the father's visible Glory
seeing the Son of God in his glorified
physical body of Flesh and no one can
remain there who is sinful because if
you're sinful you have to leave now if
the Earthly
Tabernacle was so strict in that the
high priest could only enter once a year
and made sure that he made purification
so he could be pure enough to answer
once a year and then immediately
leave how much
more do you
assume that those in heaven were
beholding the actual throne and seeing
God and His visible glory in Christ how
much more pure and holy must they be to
remain permanently before him they have
to be sinless
right yeah from the reasoning that
you're giving yes well I mean think
about it the Earthly one could he enter
sinful no what would happen to him if he
did he die it says he die yeah he die
right and tradition says they would tie
a rope to his ankle in case he dropped
dead because no one could go after him
because they die too right correct so
then here's my question to Protestants
if you could not enter the shadow the
mercy SE which the shadow of the throne
in Heaven unless you're absolutely pure
and then you have to leave how did Mary
contain all the fullness of God God
Almighty in his fullness in her womb if
[Music]
she was capable of sinning throughout
that entire
period my natural instinct would just
say it's flesh Christ's flesh in the
womb but the high priest had flesh and
he still couldn't enter unless he was
completely pure enough to enter once a
year and then he had to leave oh so I I
see the picture you're paying you're
saying say frce the um temple in it of
itself is Mary then the inner Sanctuary
what is Jesus physical
body he says it's a temple of God
destroy this Temple I raise it up in
three days right it's physical body
great but that physical body was taken
from
whom yeah so my question is if he's God
and all his fullness and he's
tabernacling in her womb could she
have sinned for a second containing God
in all his fullness for that entire
period that she conceived
him you know they answer no no my L just
had a brain for it so sorry hit me one
more time my
apologies if you cannot sin for even a
moment and be in God's presence without
incurring his
wrath how did Mary contain God in all
his fullness in the fullness of deity in
her womb for the entire period if she
was capable of sinning or she actually
sinned she have to be
sinless I see she have to be sinless got
it so that means now you're one step
closer to the ancient teaching of the of
the fathers which
are the same teachings in the Orthodox
Catholic church so that means at least
for that entire period She had to have
been sinless but then they say well hold
on since God deliberately created her to
be the vessel from which Christ would
take flesh why would it be a stretch of
imagination that Christ in his grace
saved her from ever actually sinning
because she was prepared for that honor
of giving to him his flesh which would
be the temple of
God oh okay I see you understand
implying um kind of like uh how they
they they Sanctified the temple prior to
ah I got you so the Christians
understood hm if Christ's physical body
is a temple of God and he took that
flesh from Mary that means when he was
in Mary she was the temple that housed
God but no unclean thing can touch God
so how could she at any moment have
sinned when God was dwelling in all his
fullness in her
womb that's how they reasoned they were
right because they looked at the Earthly
tabac looked at the Heavenly Temple wow
the high priest could only enter once a
year in the most holy place and he had
to be absolutely pure because if there
was any stain of sin right on his part
and if the sacrif defected he'd be
killed dead how could then Mary contain
God and His fullness in her belly if she
even sinned for a
second out of curiosity which early
Church Father wrote that CU I like to go
read it the early church fathers that
spoke of her being the new Eve and the
Ark of the Covenant yes sir so I mean
there are many but I got to find my
articles for you I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
not trying to um no no I know but that's
I'm saying so if you if you type it in
let me go to my blog that she's the new
Eve and she's the Arc of the
Covenant
because when she says um when Christ is
saying son um say it again I can't hear
you sorry when reference to the Cross
when he's on the cross he says uh woman
yep that's right that's I just did a
talk on it earlier it's that's the
Illusions in Genesis 3 yes so I see the
Illusions so I'm just trying to figure
out what's the extent of the illusions
that are being brought forth from the
Old
Testament because I just did like open a
I just did open air preaching today off
of marriage and how the illusion of
marriage and walking with Christ and you
shouldn't say friends get angry with
your wife due to the fact the anger was
already dealt with on the
cross say it again because I'm not
saying the connection you're making as
I'm trying to find you the article sorry
so safeer when um when a husband so you
see as Paul in Ephesians chapter 5 he
says husbands love your wife as Christ
loved the church willing to give up
yourself for her and this is a great
mystery that's being uh that's that
Paul's saying so when I was preaching
ing over marriage um I shouldn't say FR
get angry with my wife or say FR show my
wrath towards wife when that anger
towards sin was already dealt with in
Christ so the sinful anger which Christ
was speaking about on The Sermon on the
Mount this anger I shouldn't be I'm
trying to see the connection with Mary
because I don't know where you're going
with oh no no no no this is not not this
is not a reference to Mary my apologies
this I'm just very confused because
Christ and the church are pref Tried by
Adam and Eve correct I'm trying to say
what's the what's Con in Genesis 224 it
says for this reason a man shall leave
his father mother and cling to his wife
and the two shall become one flesh
Ephesians 5:30 to 32 Paul says that this
is actually about Christ and the
church he says that was meant to be a
picture of Christ in the church so from
the beginning Adam and Eve were designed
to prefigure foreshadow Christ and the
church because Christ is the last Adam
and his bride would be the last Eve
that would be the church but the church
is undergoing purification and
glorification and sanctification so just
like Eve had the propensity to sin due
to the Serpent's cunning Paul warns the
Corinthian Church in 2 Corinthians 111:4
that he fears for them that they will
lose their virginity by the seduction of
the
serpent just like the serpent deceived e
by his cunning you too may be deceived
from
your
devotion belief and faith in the
Simplicity of the gospel of
Christ so according to Paul Adam and Eve
were designed to be a picture of Christ
in the church so though Adam and Eve
exist and they're actual historical
persons they were designed to point to a
greater reality because it all points to
Christ and that's why he says in
Ephesians
53-32 he quot quotes Genesis 2:24 and
Ephesians 5:31 he goes and lo I speak of
a mystery I speak of Christ in the
church he's saying that is actually
about Christ in the church now how many
marriages took place in the garden now
by the way everyone got the article that
I sent you about Mary as a new EVE it's
right there send in the scripture box
how many marriages took place in the
garden only one how many one how many
will take place in the New
Garden one yep